4,6 Millionen abgelaufene Impfdosen
lagern bei -25°. das gab das
Gesundheitsministerium auf Anfrage von
FDP Vize Wolfgang Kubicki bekannt eine
Begründung aus dem Hause Lauterbach
warum diese Massen an Impfstoff nicht
schon längst entsorgt werden ja man
könne eventuell eine Verlängerung der
Haltbarkeit erreichen naja also man
könnte natürlich noch diese Dosen jetzt
einfach weg tun wenn sie verbraucht sind
nicht man braucht werden können ich bin
der Meinung dass man sowieso viel zu
viel gekauft hat und ich bin auch der
Meinung dass man insgesamt bei Corona am
drastisch übertrieben hat wo ist der
Politiker der jetzt einfach sagt okay
Leute wir haben vor ein zwei Jahren
Fehler gemacht ja das wird doch jeder
verstehen weil keiner das besser machen
kann aber jetzt muss eine Entscheidung
ja dann wenn da 4,6 Millionen ranzige
Schweinehälften hängen ja und gekühlt
werden dann kommen die auch im nächsten
Tagen die tierkörperverwertungsanstalt
da muss eine Entscheidung her ja und
nicht so eine faule Ausrede ja wir haben
noch eine wir suchen noch einen Weg die
Schweinehälfte die das Ganze zu